these are my disclosures. So we talk about CAR-T-cells and frontline therapy for myeloma. We're
really not talking about truly giving CARs to untreated newly diagnosed patients. These studies
are always constructed as consolidation studies because it's not practical to really give a truly
newly diagnosed patient myeloma, or sorry, truly newly diagnosed patient CAR-T-cell therapy.
So I highlight this one just because it's one of the few that's really been fully published and
then is also going forward in a larger phase study. So this is GC012F, which is the combo
CD19-BCMA CAR, now with AstraZeneca, with a different name that I can't remember,
ADD0120, I think. So these are patients, they got a couple cycles of VRD,
and then went on to receive CyFlu and CAR-T-cells. And one issue with all these studies you'll see
is that a few patients during the induction pre-CAR phase peel off the study because maybe
they had very aggressive disease and blew through induction. And so when you see the
results at the end, you also have to interpret that maybe some of the higher risk patients were
selected off. But this is kind of typical of what we see where your patients come in
with a smattering of responses, they get the CAR-T-cell, you see very high rates of MRD negative
CR afterwards and good progression-free survival, but still not cure. So we still see at least one
patient just in this relatively early follow-up has progressed. You see favorable safety generally,
so primary hematologic AEs, 27% all-grade CRS, all low-grade CRS,
no neurotoxicity. And then with this particular CAR, you don't see long-term persistence,
as I said, 100% MRD negative CR. So that's really impressive.
This is a similar design, although doing the consolidation a bit later. And so this is
cohort D of CAR-T-2. So this was a small group of patients who were in a pilot phase,
evaluated if they had less than CR after induction plus transplant. They got CyFlu, Cilta-cells,
and then resumed blend maintenance. And that's an interesting aspect too. So when we're using
CAR-T-cells as part of first-line therapy where it's not so much one and done like we think about
in the relapse setting, oftentimes these studies are testing resuming maintenance therapy and
recognizing that even CAR-T-cells are not reliably curing patients. So maybe we do have to resume the
maintenance therapy. Again, you see really impressive 94% of the patients upgrade to CR
or stringent CR, most of those being MRD negative. But still, you're still seeing some patients who
relapse even after this intensive course of therapy, transplant, and CAR-T-cells. You're
still seeing CRS, but it's all low-grade. And so probably a safer setting with lower disease burden.
But still, even in this low disease burden setting, I mean, these patients are not just
effectively bridged. They're really kind of in a good remission when they come into the CAR-T-cell
therapy. You're still seeing some of these serious neurologic toxicities. Even if they're
low-grade, they're disturbing and they can last for a while and not necessarily completely reversed,
but no, they're not necessarily completely reversed. But no,
no movement in neurotoxic, no Parkinsonism. Interestingly, one MDS emerging in this study,
and we'll talk later about some of these second malignancy risks.
This is a study that Sergio alluded to earlier that we worked on in the BMT-CTN. This is giving
Ida-cel and kind of a similar setting patients who failed to achieve CR after induction plus
transplant, and then a few months of lenalidomide maintenance. These patients got CyFlu, Ida-cel,
and then resumed len maintenance. We showed that patients could,
safely resumed len maintenance in this setting, and that we saw really nice improvements in
response. And so 79% of patients at 12 months converting to CR, 90% upgrading their response.
And again, Sergio was alluding earlier to where maybe what there might be a sweet spot for Ida-cel.
This could be that kind of setting because you really see no neurologic toxicity,
no secondary malignancies so far, all low-grade CRS. And so if we're, and if we're talking about
in a frontline setting, first-line therapy using CARs, we really want to have a high safety
bar, and maybe with a less potent, but more safe CAR like Ida-cel, that's a sweet spot for it.
So there's a couple of phase three studies. These were alluded to earlier. So CARTITUDE-5
and CARTITUDE-6 that in a randomized setting where patients are enrolling at very early on,
enrolling to receive CARs in a randomized setting as part of first-line therapy. And so these are
better study designs because you don't worry about the selection away from patients who maybe progress
early on. They'll be able to do it in a better way. And so we're looking at a lot of these studies
that will be included in these analyses. And so we'll see what the results of these show over time.
These studies still don't address the crucial question of sequencing though. And so if we see
that the CAR-T-cell arm in a frontline study does better, we really have to be confident that we
couldn't get the same long-term outcome by using that CAR-T-cell in second-line therapy. And I
think that's really important because we have really good data for CAR-T-cells in second and
third-line therapy. And the question will be, depending on the particular CAR you're talking to,
do we have to take in terms of risk, right? Even if it's a low rate of risk for serious toxicity in
frontline therapy, we have to be confident that we're getting something special by giving it
earlier as opposed to putting off that risk until later. And we already see a little bit of that
emerging in the second and third-line CAR-T-cell data. And so first, as we heard over and over,
DARA-VRD, even with transplant and long-term maintenance therapy, is super safe and super
effective. And so the safety bar should be very, very high. And so we're looking at a lot of
new treatments in the first-line therapy. And so this is looking even at CAR-T-4, where we're using
CAR-T-cells in one to three prior lines of therapy. You see that maybe even in first relapse,
there might be a little bit of a survival hit you take giving CAR-T-cells due to the risk entailed
in that when you have, as the comparator, very, very effective second-line therapy,
a standard therapy. And I think that question is even more pressing as you move into early
lines of therapy and first-line therapy. And a question of whether you can recoup the benefit
of earlier CARs with later CARs, I think we learned something from CARMA-3. So this was
similar study, Ida-cel in two to four prior lines of therapy, and patients could cross over. And so
you saw a progression-free survival benefit by giving the CARs earlier, but there was no overall
survival benefit, largely because patients who progressed were able to get CAR-T-cells in second
line of therapy. And so that tells us that it may not be important exactly when you give the CAR-T-cells,
at some point, and therefore you have to pick the time in patient's journey when the risk is most
justified. And then finally, I won't rehash what we already heard from Scott just earlier.
The obvious, the elephant in the room here when thinking about CARs in first-line therapy are the
T-cell engagers. And if we think about CARs as a bit more complex, maybe a bit less predictable
risk profile, when you have results like this, where you have super high response rates,
number of denegativity rates, this is JSTIC-5, which Scott mentioned, even after three cycles
100% were MRD-negative after six cycles, 100% were MRD-negative at 10 to the minus six. And so
if we think MRD-negativity is long-term prognostic, it's hard to see how you do better than this. And
so you have to say, okay, if we're going to use CAR-T-cells instead, are they safer, or are they
in some other way more preferable? And so I think the appeal of CAR-T-cells would be that it is
one and done in this setting, whereas the bispecifics would entail some longer-term
exposure and risk. The consolidation approach with CAR-T-cells does seem
safer, but doesn't eliminate all the toxicity. But again, the tolerance for even rare toxicities,
they're serious and long-lasting, will be low considering the exceptional safety of
the alternatives. But I wonder, as we think about TCE-based therapies with fixed duration and
shorter regimens, could we get a lot of the benefit that we think of coming from CAR-T-cells and being
one and done, but in the form of a more accessible and more predictable therapy? That's all. Thank you very much.